I halt in military operations in Yemen
but in the days and even hours before
the ceasefire came into effect all too
familiar scenes of violence across the
country injured people taken to hospital
after Houthi rebels shelled the port
city of her Dada more injuries too
intense after heavy shelling the Houthis
say the Saudi UAE coalition also bombed
targets in our Jeff Hager and Saida
although the coalition called for a
ceasefire a Houthi spokesman told Al
Jazeera they have not agreed to it so
long as the siege is not lifted we have
all rights to use our missile systems
our maritime and air defenses including
the drones will continue to target their
military installations and industrial
sites is nothing but a continuation of
war the coalition is just manipulating
words either a total cease and halt
facilities and enter the siege where the
war will continue the Saudi vice defense
minister Hallett bin Solomon said on
Twitter that the kingdom has taken
responsibility to bring stability to the
region but some analysts believe we are
in the UAE are looking for a face-saving
way out of an expensive war they cannot
win and the UN special envoy to Yemen
Martin griffiths has called for all
parties to urgently cease fighting and
make progress towards peace
more than 100,000 people have been
killed in Yemen since a conflict began
five years ago the UN hopes the
temporary ceasefire could be extended
the warring sides are expected to hold a
video conference to discuss halting
ground air and naval attacks but
millions of people are on the brink of
famine a millions more are suffering
from displacement from their homes and
disease UN officials hope the lull in
fighting means they can prevent another
dangerous disease from entering the
country coronavirus they fear Yemen's
healthcare system is already on the
verge of collapse and it simply won't be
able to cope with another outbreak nor
about a mani al-jazeera well the push to
end the fighting in Yemen began back in
2018 when the two sides met for talks in
Sweden a truce was reached around the
port city of heard Aida and both sides
agreed to pull their forces out of the
area that ceasefire held until May last
year but fighting resumed when the
withdrawal from her data never
materialized the Saudi air campaign
continued and Houthi forces began a
series of drone strikes on targets in
Saudi Arabia the biggest attack happened
in September targeting oil processing
plants in the east causing massive
disruption to the kingdom's oil
production and more than a hundred
thousand people have been killed in
Yemen since the conflict began it's also
led to a humanitarian crisis that's
pushed millions to the brink of famine
well after enough there is a Yemen
researcher at Human Rights Watch and she
says the Houthi demands may not be right
at this time I personally think it's a
very interesting demand to make given
how the whole world seems becoming like
Yemen where travel restrictions are
imposed in so many places and this is
not the right time to present that a
very you know a crucial demand and in a
long list the travel restrictions might
be deterring a fully outbreak in Yemen
at this moment but what were really
concerned about is what could
happen if an outbreak arrives today so
within few hours or a few days this is
also mentioned by some health officials
from the whooping about 1 million people
could be infected with kroehner virus
within days so I don't really understand
how they can't put this kind of demand
as a very crucial in that